هنا قتلت اسرائيل ثلاثه فلسطينيين واعتقلت
رابعا في عمليه قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الفلسطينيين الاربعه اطلقوا النار على
نقطه للجيش الاسرائيلي صباحا فقتل ثلاثه
منهم واصيب رابع تم اعتقاله لاحقا وبحسب
المصادر الفلسطينيه فان الاربعه ينتمون
الى تنظيم عرين الاسود في مدينه نابلس
وكانوا في طريقهم لاطلاق النار على نقطه
عسكريه اسرائيليه بين قريتي جيت وصار غرب
نابلس مشهد بات يتكرر يوميا تقريبا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه حداد واضرار يشل
الحركه التجاريه في المدن الفلسطينيه عقب
مقتل فلسطينيين فقد قتل منذ بدايه العام
الحالي برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من
ثمانين فلسطينيه
من مدينه نابلس شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
خالد القاسم العربي